so listen uh I really want to start with
I'm a huge fan of the show I really want
to thank you guys for a fantastic season
uh and uh congrats on being Mr McAdams
oh thank you thank you I appreciate that
took a lot of hard work Dave I
definitely have to ask uh are you and
Robin over you know we write one season
at a time uh but it certainly feels like
you know that I had a choice to make at
the end and I made the other choice so
um I think it's really cool in a season
where it's like
yeah yeah I'm looking for love the whole
time and I think deep down like there's
kind of his dual like uh interweaving
themes of like love and like validation
and fame and I think kind of like they
interweave and there's so much overlap
between the two and even between the
Quest for both for my character and I
think the interesting thing about the
ending is you know you think you know
this experience with this stalker and
Brad Pitt has made you made me like
totally like rethink everything and like
I'm I now know what's important in life
and I'm gonna go for a love and Robin
and it's a huge mislead uh and the
reality is that I it's like if I still
need all this validation it still irks
me that I can't like get to a guy like
Drake then I clearly don't even fully
love myself yet and until you like
actually love yourself you can't really
take anyone along that ride with you you
know what I mean and I think that's a so
I think on the one hand it could be
appeared like he'd abandoned Robin in
love for like being
famous and cool and Rich and but I also
view it as like he was there's like a
self-awareness of like
not stringing someone along until the
person is is ready you know yeah I
definitely have to ask you
um I can see that you are definitely a
sneakerhead and this was not in my list
of questions but in an emergency there's
a fire what's the pair or two that
you're grabbing to absolutely save I'm
gonna grab the Jordan one bridge and I'm
gonna grab a running pair of New Balance
that's all I need God I can see at the
lower left uh there's some shoes that I
uh admire
um so I I read and obviously I could be
wrong that um that you auditioned to be
data even though the character was based
on you
um is that true and what was that like
uh that's definitely true a lot of
people don't know that but I like to say
that because it's the real story and at
the same time it was challenging but I
knew I had it but I was also nervous
because it was my first time acting but
Dave was just telling me like yo this is
a procedure we got to go through this FX
you know you gotta audition it's just
protocol he's like but you're gonna get
it though I'm telling you he's like I'm
banking on you so what did it it was
just like all right boom and it was
definitely
it was like uh like I didn't make gay to
like come into the casting office and go
in front of like the blue thing like me
and Gator like shot like a proof of
concept scene with both of us in it you
know what I mean it was a it was a
different but you know they had never
seen Gator it's hard to be like take my
word for it this guy is going to be the
Great Character of a show so we just had
to get some footage of me and gate on
camera but I mean as soon as I shot that
footage uh and I haven't deleted it I
saw my computer my computer's always out
of hard drive space and I it's always
just as you need it I can't delete it
because it's too historic so I keep this
like old like proof of concept of like
me and Gator walking down the street
talking mitigated in the studio talking
it was like important footage I'm gonna
tell you something recently they've
invented this thing called uh external
hard drives and um
I get all these hard drives and then I I
lose them and I like put I hide them and
I forget where I hit I'm really not yeah
I totally get it one of the things that
I love about the show is the way you two
interact and I know obviously it's all
scripted but how much after the script
or YouTube riffing to find more dialogue
and how much is it literally what's on
the page if you want to be honest uh
we definitely be ripping man like I'll
be watching the show and I'll watch
episodes and then I'll be looking at the
scene after and be like soaking it in
and I'll be like damn none of that was
on the paper so that's the beauty of it
man like me and Dave got a real great
friendship you know like real Dynamic
energies like always vibing so when we
on camera man it's just organic like
it'll be like all right this is what the
scene is about but we need you guys to
do this like if you look back on some of
the scenes like but it's just beautiful
man like I'll be watching the show and
I'll just be thinking like dang none of
that was on paper like we have the scene
blocked out but we just deliver every
time man because I really love this guy
man he loved me and we just trying to
always be great like you know after
every take he the first person I asked
like so how was it like you know Skip
past the whole director the camera angle
all that to him you know because I know
it's his show and I know what he wants
to put out there for the world so yeah
man everything is real we always say I
say a few things one the scripted
version
is just one version of well like we
always we capture that to an extent and
then but there's always and you know
we're not like going off on tangents
that are just like irrelevant that
aren't about the scene like it's like if
me and geda have to react to someone
pulling a crossbow on us for example
it's like yes there are words on paper
that we could say but really it's just
like you know like you're scared this
person has a crossbow be gated in this
moment and be scared and usually the
outcome is when it's better it's just
more naturalistic when like people are
really living in the moments of scenes
and like it's not just like the same
lines over and over again like we're
tuning each other out and just waiting
for our cue to like talk next like you
actually have to listen to what he's
going to say because it could like you
know I one of my favorite parts of the
season is in episode nine when I say
like I'm not like a a dirt bag like you
gator I don't cheat and he says uh man I
was cheating out the gate I had girls do
in fifth grade doing my homework or
something like that and then like my I
had wasn't expecting that and then I
like my reaction which was using the
show was like that's like so cool to say
and like that was me in that moment
being like that was cool uh and I think
moments like that like if we had
scripted that it just wouldn't have it
wouldn't have come through so like you
can like really feel my surprise in that
moment and it makes everything kind of
cooler oh 100
um so I definitely have to talk about
the fact that this season has had an
insane amount of guest stars but you
leveled up with the finale
um and so I want to know how exactly did
was Brad a fan uh was you know did Drake
know that you you want you know you've
been building towards Drake so how did
how did these things happen yeah no I uh
look people are you know ask me like how
did you how did you get all these people
and it's like really I hate to say it
but it's I don't hate to say it I'm
honored to say it they just love the
show and like I think it speaks to the
the greatness of the show that it
doesn't take a lot of like insane
maneuvering to get these people to do it
they all just independently Drake right
Rachel McAdams Brad Pitt they all watch
the show they love the show they watch
all the episodes like I've had run-ins
with Drake and he talks my ear off in a
really positive way about how big of a
fan he is of the show and how it's like
one of the more important shows of Our
Generation and Brad Pitt I heard that he
liked it too and I had never met him and
I took that knowledge of the fact that
oh like Brad loves the show that so I
wrote you know I figured maybe there's a
shot here and you know uh I sent a
really uh thought out email uh like that
took days to write
um and got a really cool email back and
he was in and uh Rachel McAdam same deal
she watches the show with her husband
and like they love it and so it's like
and they're not just like random
celebrity like I want you in this
because you're cool like each of them
are kind of Representative of like the
the main like themes of like what the
show is all about as far as like Rachel
McAdams is like
you know our Generations like Dream
Woman She's Like anchored like some of
the more important romantic pieces of
Cinema for like my entire generation uh
Brad Pitt like is the preeminent
representation of like movie star
Hollywood he's like the biggest icon
like I think of our time as far as
Cinema and Drake is obviously that of
music and Hip-Hop you know what I mean
and so all of those to like for the
themes that we're going for I feel like
all these characters like aren't just
coming in and like being like hey like
they're just like representing like the
top of those major thematic temples so I
think it's like it's truly uh like when
I'm working with Brad Pitt and I'm like
giving him Direction and I'm seeing him
trust me the way like he must trust like
a Tarantino or a Colin you know what I
mean like it just is very validating for
me as a filmmaker to get that type of
trust from these
these like iconic pillars of
entertainment so it's very rewarding to
like get them on board and then also to
not have to like do anything crazy to
get them Beyond just like have made a
show that they all really love and
respect one of the things I'm curious
about is uh you know like the the Mr
McAdams song is really good and the
music you guys are doing each week is
really good and I'm so curious how early
on are you writing this music for these
episodes and how much is it you know
what I mean because there's that balance
of figuring out well are we going to get
this person for this episode oh I got to
do the music like there's all of that
that has to come together yeah no it's
uh I took a lot of risks this season and
it's like a lot of people in my writer's
room were like man like
I I hope that you're right that like
these people are just gonna say yes like
people thought I was like really even in
the writer's room they were like what
are we doing writing this entire episode
around Brad Pitt you know uh without
having me ever communicated with him at
all
um and I just believed and I was
rewarded for my belief and yeah it's a
chicken and egg thing and in between
Seasons like I'm always working on music
sometimes I'll make a song that like
wasn't written for the show but I'm just
like man this scene needs like a
good rap you know this scene needs like
a romantic song and like sometimes like
I'm like oh this song I made like a year
ago really could work obviously the
verse
like that I wrote when I wrote it not
thinking of the TV show doesn't work as
well as if I like rewrote the verse and
like made it about like Robin or you
know what I mean and made it about more
of like the specific themes of the
season
um so it's a total chicken and egg thing
and everything varies but I'm fortunate
enough to like in between the seasons
I'm like working my ass off on music and
a lot of times there's it's not all for
not in the sense that like I can even
though like my fans are obviously like
craving an album and of course I wish I
could deliver that and I'm working as
hard as I can there is a fortunate
reality to this whole thing that the
show is about a rapper and I can take a
lot of music that I made independent of
the show and get it into the show in an
organic way data I definitely have to
ask you
um this what is it like when you're in a
scene with Brad
um and you are on set and you're looking
at him and how much is it sort of you
second you know what I mean because it
has to be like I've done some interviews
with some uh you know like I've sat
across from Leo and other and Tom Cruise
and there's a moment where you're
sitting across you're like [__] you know
and so I'm just curious what's it like
when you're in a scene with Brad and are
you you know how much are you thinking
oh I really got to deliver you know what
I mean yeah it's definitely a lot of
pressure but number one first and
foremost is it's a blessing you know and
then number two you gotta question
yourself and think like dang am I that
good like I gotta see with Brad Pitt
like you know so it makes you feel like
okay I gotta be on my on my a game you
know you got to really be focused you
know what I'm saying but
you really just gotta soak it in and
really appreciate it like you know I did
the same and then right now it's just
basically starting to hit me like yeah I
really gotta see with Brad Pitt you know
how people run up on George Clooney and
they'd be like so George Clooney how was
it man working with Brad they could ask
Gaya how was it working with Brad now so
I just feel like I'm in that level of
conversation and I owe it all to my
brother LD man it's just a great feeling
man just like even when I be around OD I
just be thinking like man this is this
is It's amazing man so it's gonna be
something I definitely remember forever
uh it's gonna be something that's gonna
help my career and I appreciate you LD
thanks man that was dope of course and
let me just say it's the guy who edits
the footage and sees all the takes in
the dailies like I it's even watching
data in between takes like his
excitement level like like he was like
so happy to like I could see it like and
Brad honestly did that to the entire
crew like when he was on set like you
could just feel it everyone was like
walking with such a sense of like
purpose and I really feel like you know
everyone there's a lot of people go into
making this show and I think everybody
at their core like loves storytelling
and loves Cinema and they've been
working for years on in this industry
working on things and it's like when
you're working on something that has
like the biggest star in the world at it
on your set it's like such a it's like
it really instilled a sense of purpose
and like I think everyone was like
challenged to be like we gotta like
bring our absolute a game
and and yeah yeah yeah the thing about
this season is you've raised the bars
like so high in terms of guest stars and
you know everything about the season was
so good where the F do you go in the
next season have you already started uh
thinking about it I understand the
question but I have I'm not concerned
because I had yes I have thoughts I've
been thinking about it and
I feel like even though it's different
scales every time like after season one
I felt like man what a finale like where
do we go from here like how do we beat
that I remember when we made season two
finale I was like man we're up against
the shadow of the season one finale like
how are we gonna like top what we did
and then this season is the same deal
it's like how do we like we've set such
a precedent for like season finales
being like these epic conclusions of
like the whole season and a dramatic
unpredictable way and we topped it again
and I feel you know I have I
yes like we have you know Brad Pitt
Drake Rachel McAdams they are the
absolute Mountaintop of like what they
represent for like you know the industry
and the ends but there are it's not all
about celebrities there are plenty of
other celebrities that have not been in
the show that are at their own
respective mountaintops that I would
love to get in this show and I have a
lot of really great ideas for where to
go next I already have to rap I'm just
gonna say and I really mean it sincerely
I love the show and I really appreciate
what you guys do and I wish you nothing
but the best and if we can ever help on
collider with the promotion of the show
always please let me know
thank you thank you and and you know
give a shout out to Tania the the woman
the stalker because she killed that
episode like she like I know that Drake
and Brad and but she was like a force
listen it doesn't work without an
antagonist you know and uh listen I love
the finality and again love the season I
could I could just keep going I'm just
gonna say good luck with the rest of
your interviews all right thank you and
put it all on the written piece so good
job I appreciate it thank you so much